all right everybody um you can see the
very active background the active
setting I'm in DC today wanted one of my
least favorite places on earth but I had
to be here so so here I am
alright the process is now complete the
the Boy Scouts maybe you heard the news
yesterday the Boy Scouts a once proud
and important organization and an
organization that used to help shape
boys into men is now dead it had been
dying for some time now but it is I
think it's officially official they made
the announcement yesterday that and its
announcement that even ten years ago
would it seem like some kind of
outlandish ridiculous parody but now
it's it's real it's it actually happened
the Boy Scouts said today that they're
dropping or yesterday I should say that
they're dropping boy from Boy Scouts and
they shall henceforth be known as the
Scouts because well because we're
including girls and we can't exclude
girls from the organization or from the
name and the Boy Scouts giving up their
name it's just the last and unavoidable
step in well not even really the last
step because there's more to come I'm
sure but this is just the latest step in
a in a process that's been in a
devolution that's been happening for
years now and it began it began with I
think it really began in earnest when
the Boy Scouts finally surrendered to
the left on the issue of gay scouts and
they said fine we can have gay scouts
and then the left came back and they
said ok but you need to have gay Scout
leaders and so the Boy Scouts said fine
then the left came back and they said ok
but now you need to have transgenders
and the Boy Scouts said fine but please
leave us alone after this is that this
what we're surrendering others I mean
this is it right you won't ask for more
and the left said yeah that's fine once
you just do this one last thing and
that'll be it and so they did it and
then the left came back the next day and
said oh by the way you need to admit
girls now and so the Boy Scouts always
with that steely spine immediately said
ok fine we'll admit girls and then they
said now you need to change your name
because it's exclusionary and they said
ok fine
we'll change our name and I have heard
the argument some people have said that
well it's yeah they're admitting girls
but they're still gonna separate boy and
girl troops so you're still gonna have
gender separated troops but they're all
gonna be part of the same on Brella
organization and to that I say two
things number one it's irrelevant the
fact is that they're bringing girls into
the Boy Scouts and abandoning their
identity and their name for the sake of
being inclusive and for the sake of of
being politically correct and number two
I mean have you really not noticed the
pattern yet I mean is it possible that
you haven't noticed the pattern do you
really think that that's gonna be it you
really think that they're gonna keep
gender segregated troops at this point
no of course not within within like a
year the announcements gonna come that
okay now everything is co-ed I mean
everything camping trips everything this
is I mean it's a one I 100% guaranteed
that it will happen now I'm not gonna
let my sons anywhere near this
embarrassment of an organization
and it's no longer equipped to provide
the moral example that it once provided
and the moral example that it was
founded in order to provide the Boy
Scouts originally it was supposed to be
a Christian boys organization that was
concerned not just with giving boys life
skills and teaching them about the
outdoors but with with forming them
morally moral formation and ever since
they started celebrate a surrendering to
the LGBT camp once that began then it's
they'd already forfeited that aspect of
their mission which is to say they
forfeited their mission but you know I
think that this thing with the Boy
Scouts is an example of a trend that's
been going on for a long time well two
trends one trend is organizations
surrendering to the PC mob so that's one
but the other trend is how you know we
we we don't let boys have their own
spaces anymore boys are not allowed to
have their own things you know things
that are just just belong to them this
is this is the trend we've we've gone
through and we've gotten rid of all the
spaces where boys used to come together
and just be with each other and just be
themselves you know I remember when I
was a kid a a long long time ago
but I remember when this when the big
thing this this whole process of okay we
gotta have co-ed everything we've got to
merge the genders into every activity
that's what it was kind of beginning and
so the big thing then was we got to
include all the girls in all the sports
so every baseball team every rec
baseball team that I played on there was
a token girl on the team even though or
at least where I lived there was also a
perfectly fine girl softball league and
the girls could go there and they could
play softball with the other girls and
it was great so they they did have it
sound like they didn't have sports they
could play they had a girls team but
some of the girls said no I want to be
with the boys and some of the parents
said no that's where I want to be and so
of course the league very quickly caved
to that and said fine and the girls got
to be on the team no but you know nobody
ever stopped and asked the boys no one
ever asked the boys hey do you want to
play with a girl all that mattered was
the girl wanted to play with the boys
he didn't matter if the boys want to
play with the girl its what the girl
wanted and so she got to have it so we
started you know we started taking away
all the boys sports we got to include
girls in it the
now I remember even when I was in high
school when you started seeing girls
playing football and so that's a thing
now and of course it's completely
ridiculous and even when I got think
back even to recess in elementary school
if the boys got a pickup you know game
of pick-up basketball going or they're
playing dodgeball just the boys and it
was kind of a rough and fast game very
often you'd have the finger-wagging
teacher who shows up and says now now
now you got to include everybody
you gotta include Rachel to which I get
it you got to teach kids to play
together and everything like that but
sometimes you also have to just let the
boys do their thing sometimes if the
boys are having a game and it's a rough
it's a fast game you got to let just
just let them play because you bring a
girl into it and it
I mean it ruins it I'm sorry it just
does for in many cases for the boys when
they're playing a sport when you say you
when you when you require when you
insist they have to include a girl
you're kind of ruining it because girls
are not as good as boys they're not as
athletic they're not as strong they're
not as aggressive just the fact of the
matter and the boys don't want to be as
aggressive with them with the girls as
they are with each other
so boys especially if they're playing
basketball or something if there are no
refs
then essentially every sport turns into
tackle football because they're just the
whole part of the point when boys get
together and they play a sport probably
half of the point for them is to kind of
let out their aggression and just that
physicality is a is a big and just just
clobber each other that's a big part of
the point when you start injecting girls
into it well they can't really they
don't feel right they don't want to do
that with girls
and they shouldn't do that with girls
and so it just changes the dynamic and
this is what happens when you there are
different time there's a dynamic when
you've got a bunch of boys together
doing something there's a certain
dynamic you got a bunch of girls
together doing something there's a
certain dynamic when you combine them it
changes the dynamic completely and we've
moved far beyond sports at this point of
course now this can be found everywhere
in our culture girls are constantly
breaking into the boys clubs and they're
always celebrated for their trailblazing
achievement when they break into the
boys club is hey I'm in the boys club
now but what is the achievement exactly
the boys club was a boys club for a
reason it's a club for boys when you get
rid of the boys qualifier you have
destroyed the clubs and tighter purpose
so what's your achievement you've just
you've just ruined it is what you've
done
and you can see it's not just with boys
it's even with men's lodges used to be a
big thing and now they either don't
exist or they're not nearly as prevalent
because even men Believe It or Not
sometimes like to have places they can
go where it's just themselves but we say
that's no longer permitted and yet even
as we get rid of all these boy spaces
these boys or boy organizations
we haven't gotten rid of the need that
men have and boys have for that kind of
male bonding that's still there
especially for young men
and there's a reason why there's a
pretty good reason why boys don't want
to include girls and everything not just
with sports but even if they're just
hanging out or if they're in the woods
for the Boy Scouts sometimes they don't
want to include the girls even in that
context and the reason is that adding a
girl into the picture as I said it
changes the dynamic they feel like they
have to tone things down they the
feminized things for the sake of the
girl and now even worse there's this
added pressure for the boys where they
feel like they got to impress her and
they're not able to just enjoy
themselves and relax and be themselves
now in this in that free and open
environment that exists between boys now
they got to impress the girl everything
now is about the girl you got a group of
boys you inject one girl into it and now
everything is about her and that's why
you have girls sometimes who insist on
being a part of the boy things they want
to do the boy things I want to be in the
boy organizations they want to play the
boys sports they want to intrude on all
the boy areas I think I think most girls
don't want that they also want to have
their own spaces and they don't
necessarily want to be surrounded by 50
boys right
the girls who do want that the reason
they want it is because they know it's
gonna be all about them and they're
gonna get attention it's
attention-seeking is what it is when
you've got a boy sport girl sport and
almost everyone you know boys are
playing the boy sport girl playing the
girls are playing the girl sport
everyone's having fun and then you have
that one girl who insists no I want to
be in the boy sport I want to be there
this is where adults have to come in and
say no you okay it's what you want but
you can't have it you let them have
their fun this is over here for you you
can't have everything you want I know
you want to do it you want to you know
you want the attend the attention but
you can't always have the attention you
want and I wonder where where are the
adults sometimes to say no just let the
boys have their time just let the boys
into their play playing a game there
don't just let him have it let him play
leave them alone so when when the girl
enters into the picture then she becomes
the kind of the focal point especially
when you've got young younger boys
teenage boys especially the girl becomes
the focal point because no matter how we
we think we live in this progressive
enlightened age but at the end of the
day the boys still see the girl as a
girl and they will treat her like that
and that's just human nature it's not
ever gonna change I know and it's not
just girls to you sometimes you hear
women who will say who will say oh I
have a lot of guy friends and what I'm
hanging out with them I'm just one of
the guys I'm just one of the guys you
hear from that hear that from women
sometimes and of course you hear that
and you think you don't want to say it
out loud I will now but
when you hear it you think to yourself
no you're not you're not actually one of
the guys
maybe they may have told you that they
see you that way but they don't that
they're lying to you're not one of the
guys which is fine because you're a girl
and that's fantastic but you're not one
of the guys just like they're not one of
the girls when you're hanging out with a
group of guys you're not you're not one
of them because you're not a guy you
don't have the same connection with the
guys that they have with each other you
don't understand them the way that they
understand each other it's just it's not
the same bond now if you marry one of
those guys then you will come to
understand him and know him better than
anyone else on earth including himself I
have no doubt that my wife knows me
better than anyone she knows me better
than I know myself half the time and
through him I think you'll start to
understand men generally but just a
single woman in a as a member of a group
of guys as just a friend no you don't
have the same connection you're not one
of the guys and it's just a different
dynamic which you might not realize
because women a woman is not going to
observe in the interaction between men
unless she's a part of it right most of
the time so she she sees how they are
when she's around and they she assumes
well this is how they are they're just
being natural they're being themselves
not quite it does change when you're not
there just like it does with women
that's
natural natural thing
and then a woman might say well I cuss
and spit and burp and rustle roun
wrestle around in the mud like like guys
I'm just like that I'm yeah I'm just I'm
a I'm just like him now if that's
actually true and I find that probably
90% of the time when a woman makes this
claim but she's just like the guys and
she's you know rough-and-tumble probably
90 to 95 percent of the time that's not
true at all but for the fight to ten
percent of the time when it is true
here's the thing when guys look at a
woman imitating and kind of aping male
behavior they're gonna think one of two
things they're gonna think either she's
hot so I'll play along or - this is sad
and I wish she would stop because the
truth is again no matter what our
progressive enlightened culture says the
truth is men don't want women to act
like men men want women to act like
women
they may pretend they may say oh no they
may pretend to be completely egalitarian
and they don't see any difference
between the genders and they think it's
just great when a woman behaves in this
kind of masculine manly way they may
pretend that they think it's cool and
they think it's just awesome but they
don't even right now in the comments
there may be a guy who says who pretends
and says oh no I you know I've got a
group of friends who are girls and I
don't see him any differently than I see
the guys and I'm exactly the same with
them as I am with the guys no difference
he may claim that but if it were just
the two of us sitting in the car having
a man-to-man conversation he would be
agreeing with everything I'm saying
100%
meant men like it when women act like
women that's what they want out of a
woman they don't want a woman who tries
to act like a man
because there are men for that
wanted to talk to a man be around a man
while there are plenty of men in the
world
but they rely on women to be women just
like I assume women rely on men to be
men we have this idea nowadays that men
and women are exactly the same and so
that's where we get this co-ed thing
where everything has to be co-ed
everything can be we think that
everything can be co-ed without losing
anything in translation because we have
this idea that men and women are exactly
the same and of course they are not and
from there we get this idea that men and
women can be friends with each other in
exactly the same way you know they could
be friends with members of the same sex
in exactly the same way that they're
friends with members of the opposite sex
which also is not true this is just
something it's like so I think for my
generation a lot of us we got this idea
from TV because I know growing up in the
90s a lot of the shows you watched on
Nickelodeon or whatever else this was a
big thing they were pushing and I feel
like half of these shows the main
character would be like a preteen or
teenage girl and her and her best friend
in life is a boy they're they're just
partners in crime there's no attraction
there they're just partners a crime
coming of age together right girl and
boy what was that show I don't remember
that what was the show on in the 90s
that everyone watched
where it was a girl and her best friend
was a boy and he would climb on a ladder
he would climb through her window to
come visit her and the parents were
totally cooled out Clarissa explains it
all was the show now we're gonna get
into a whole 90s conversation but that
was the show that is one of the shows on
Nickelodeon in the 90s and the main
character was this teenage girl and her
best friend was a boy and they were just
hanging out and so we got it into our
head that this is how it works
in real life but it's it's not really
how it works
guarantee again guaranteed you got a
teenage boy and he's claiming that his
best friend is a girl he's attracted to
her ten times out of ten 100% guaranteed
now when you wouldn't when you get
married then your spouse really does
become your best friend your partner for
life and you have the closest most
intimate bond obviously hopefully with
with your spouse but before you're
married and you're single
generally your closest bonds are gonna
be with members of the same sex your
best friend if you're a girl is gonna be
a girl if it's a guy it's gonna be a guy
that's natural it's just the way it goes
because again you just have a different
connection with those people because you
understand them because they're just
like you and that's why it's so
important to allow girls and boys to
have their own spaces girls - I'm not
only mean to leave them out it's just
that number one I'm not a girl so I
can't speak to that as much number two I
think girls are already allowed to have
their own spaces with one big exception
of course we know that girls are not
allowed to have their own locker rooms
and bathrooms anymore
which is insane and dangerous but even
there you notice that the price of entry
for a boy if he wants to get into the
girl spaces is he has to pretend that he
is a girl
whereas for the boys no girls can come
in and there's no charade enough to
pretend they're a boy it's just the boys
are not allowed to have that so
girls need to have their own spaces too
fortunately I think they are allowed for
the most part to have their own spaces
and also boys generally don't have the
desire or the urge to intrude into
female spaces if they're a bunch of
girls sitting around having a
conversation or doing something most
guys aren't going to say to themselves
oh I got to go be a part of that what
they're more likely to say is oh okay
all the girls are contained over here
let's go let's go over here and do
something else so you don't find in guys
this desire to be seen as one of the
girls
you're not often gonna find a guy
bragging that I'm just one of the girls
just like him
even in our enlightened age if a guy
went around saying that he would be
ridiculed rightly so by his male friends
maybe that will change as we become even
more enlightened but as of right now
that's how it goes because it's natural
so
let's just let's all let's all just give
each other some space right I think we I
think we could all use it is my point
all right that's it for me thanks for
watching thanks for listening Godspeed
everybody